a sus 78 años finalmente joe biden
disfrutó de su primer día en la oficina
más poderosa del mundo tras el protocolo
de la inauguración como presidente
empezó el trabajo
estoy orgulloso de las acciones
ejecutivas de hoy comenzaré por cumplir
las promesas que le hice al pueblo
estadounidense es un largo camino por
recorrer son acciones ejecutivas y son
importantes pero vamos a necesitar mucha
legislación en su primer día va a ir en
firma una serie de órdenes ejecutivas
revirtiendo políticas de la
administración trump y tomando nuevas
decisiones destaca la vuelta de eeuu al
acuerdo climático de parís ya la
organización mundial de la salud un
mayor esfuerzo contra el kobe 19 fin a
la prohibición de viajar a países de
mayoría musulmana protecciones para los
beneficiarios del programa daca y un
proyecto de ley que busca ofrecer un
camino a la ciudadanía para 11 millones
de indocumentados
jen psaki secretaria de prensa de la
casa blanca desveló cómo será la gestión
de la migración
la prioridad del presidente reflejada en
la orden es manejar responsablemente la
frontera mantener a las familias unidas
incentivar el crecimiento económico
atender las causas de la migración desde
centroamérica y asegurarse de que eeuu
seguirá siendo un refugio para aquellos
que huyen de la persecución
además baiden firmó el fin de la
declaración de emergencia que servía
para dotar de fondos la construcción del
muro entre eeuu y méxico y órdenes para
impulsar la igualdad justicia racial y
la defensa de las minorías tampoco
perdió el tiempo en su primer día la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
harris juró a tres nuevos miembros
demócratas los dos obtenidos en georgia
además de alex padilla primer senador
latino por california que ocupará el
escaño de la vicepresidenta en el senado
a pesar de que demócratas y republicanos
cuentan con 50 senadores hardies tendrá
el voto clave que decantara las
decisiones
tras la jura la primera votación del
senado donde se confirmó a abril heinz
como secretaria de inteligencia